people are traveling compared to 2020
because of the pandemic
yeah the u.s travel association says
about 80 percent of americans are
planning a trip this summer
i'm in the process of doing that myself
i think you are too alex memorial days
on the horizon airlines are adding
flights to their schedules just in time
for the summer
hector mejia live this morning at
mccarran airport with a look at the
trends they're seeing there right now
hector good morning to you
good morning and count me and i'm also
ready for a summer getaway and
as we talk about this and the expected
increased demand
airlines are also listening and they are
adding new destinations also because
trends are changing so it's not just the
destination to let's say
new york city or for disney world
joining us live to talk about those
trends we have joe rachel good morning
to you good morning
so what are we seeing right now things
are changing and uh new destinations
flying out of mccarran for those
domestic flights
absolutely you know we're saying that
people after the past year are looking
for something a little bit different
um you know we've seen the desire to get
into the great outdoors has increased so
we're seeing you know
increased service to montana wyoming
north dakota oregon just places where
people can go outside
and experience those great outdoors and
you know people are also ready to hit
the beach and so we have service in
california increased service to hawaii
florida
just anything where people can kind of
get outside and unwind after this last
year
and it's so exciting to be back inside
the airport you guys are looking live at
the tsa line right over at the uh
checkpoint c
memorial day right around the corner
also the unofficial start to summer
before that rolls in what should people
know before they pack their bags and
even book their trip
absolutely you know we want people to
you know plan ahead know the
requirements for the destinations that
they're going to
you know with these new cdc guidelines
everything's a little bit different no
matter the location and so just make
sure you know what you're
expected to do when you get there and
then also just to remember that
masks are still mandatory in the airport
other transportation hubs and on the
airplane so
you know be prepared to wear that mask
you know as you travel and uh speaking
about that where does uh
international travel stand right now you
know we have a handful of dust or
excuse me a handful of flights to mexico
come to different cities in mexico so
people that want to go to the beaches or
explore some of the history
of mexico have that opportunity to do so
but right now because of the current
restrictions
the only non-stop service to a different
country out of mccarran is that only
mexico right now
correct right now we just have direct
service to mexico internationally
you know that's a good point if people
are flying international they need to
make sure that they know what those
requirements are when they try to return
to the united states and to be able to
plan accordingly um to meet those needs
awesome thank you so much for having us
and let me just show you the line again
it's been on and off right now it's not
as long but earlier
we were seeing a lot more people going
through this checkpoint
and i point that out because this last
sunday was the busiest
since the start of the pandemic for tsa
checkpoints all across the country
seeing just about 1.85 million
passengers
on sunday alone all right reporting live
inside mccarron hector mejia 8 news now
back to you guys